johnny depp versus amber heard why
lawyers were back in court today welcome
to entertainment tonight rachel smith
here in la with me kevin fraser and
michelle turner are in rehearsals to
host tonight's daytime emmys and of
course we'll check in with them in just
a few yes but first the new legal move
in johnny's defamation case
today's court hearing lasted roughly 30
minutes and the judge did what the judge
said she was going to do she rendered a
judgment on the verdict that was found
while the judge finalized johnny's win
amber still isn't done her spokesperson
said today you don't decline to appeal
if you know you are right but legal
expert julie rendellman says this could
cost her in order for amber her to
appeal she must post the judgment that
was found against her by the jury which
is over 10 million dollars in addition
she has to post six percent of that
judgment each year in order to go
forward with that appeal
trial breakout star camille vazquez
wasn't in court but was spotted out all
smiles in new york city yesterday
johnny's believed to be in norway though
his concert scheduled there for tonight
has been postponed according to media
there someone in his band has coveted
and news today about another battle
between exes what doesn't kill you makes
you strong
kelly clarkson versus brandon blackstock
divorce is a really
thing kelly's ex has apparently moved
out of their montana ranch and into this
1.8 million dollar montana home the
ranch had been a sticking point in the
split it seems that they've settled on
issues regarding custody child support
as well as alimony the next hearing is
july 15th and how has kelly been getting
through i don't know how anybody i'll
just be real with you goes through grief
like divorce without having an outlet i
have written like 60 songs kelly seemed
to signal brandon's dislike for la when
she covered this billy eilish song
changing you made me hate this city
you know you're under a microscope
kelly's also finding comfort in close
friends she talked to the chicks about
it on her talk show earlier this month
okay so we all went through divorces and
not just music i think it's therapeutic
but like your female friendships i feel
like that has really helped me
[Music]